[Aplausos]
recuerdo como si estuviese en mi pupitre
sentado la primera vez que debatía mi
profesora de lengua margarita una mañana
decidió que los ocho mejores de la clase
llegó nos nombró por notas vais a hacer
un debate para mí aquello era algo
aterrador ya de por sí pero cuando
escuché el tema todavía me preocupo
mucho más porque la pregunta era si la
guerra tenía de algún modo algún efecto
positivo en la sociedad las posturas se
sorteaban y a mí me daba pánico que me
tocas a favor hoy en día sabemos que esa
pregunta fue una mala pregunta margarida
también está en nuestra red pero por
aquel entonces incluso con aquella
pregunta aprenden muchas cosas sabéis
qué postura me tocó
a favor me pase una semana buscando
argumentos metido en papeles libros
internet para entender cómo de algún
modo podría defender aquello pero
incluso en una postura tan polarizada en
un ejercicio donde las posturas donde la
favor y el en contra eran polos opuestos
encontré argumentos y encontré valores
que me permitían aumentar el prisma con
el que veía el conflicto la guerra
seguía siendo mala para mí aunque
hubiese defendido que tiene efectos
positivos pero la entendía mucho mejor
un debate básicamente es una situación
en la que dos equipos de cuatro personas
cinco depende de cada momento se
enfrentan como un tema que conocen de
antemano se investigan donde las
posturas son sorteadas y donde existe un
número de jueces indeterminado que
decide quién gana en función a un
reglamento dado más tarde en la
universidad
llegué de rebote a otro torneo de debate
no sé ni cómo pero nos invitaron y
cuatro amigos nos lanzamos a acudir pues
a otra provincia invitados por una
universidad para defender pues nuestro
equipo y nuestras ideas el tema esta vez
era si había que apostar en españa' por
energía nuclear año 2010
la cosa o lo que pasó allí fue curioso
porque pasaban fundamentalmente dos
cosas la primera que perdimos de forma
estrepitosa no nos ganamos ni un debate
porque estábamos muy fuera de juego
íbamos sin trajes y todo el mundo iba
con una corbata hasta aquí y ataun no
comprendíamos las normas debatíamos sin
ni siquiera es un formato y claro no
podíamos ganar por muy veraces que
fuesen nuestros argumentos por muy
sólidos que fuésemos por muy
convincentes que pues hemos no jugábamos
en su terreno de juego estábamos
completamente fuera de su sistema no
teníamos capital no teníamos mentor
éramos amateurs que habíamos llegado a
que el mundo y que por muy bien que
hablásemos no podíamos ganar la segunda
que pasó fue más curioso que solamente
hubo dos equipos que salieron contentos
y felices de aquel torneo nosotros que
perdimos todos y el campeón que ganó
todos y aquello nos sorprendió cuando
volvimos a casa
buscamos un capitán queríamos ganar y
vengarnos pero también hicimos otra cosa
antes de empezar a entrenar que fue
apuntar en un papel todas aquellas cosas
que nos habían gustado de aquel
encuentro y todas las que no
las que veíamos como algo que tengo que
se hará esto cuando las dividimos en
post-its nos dimos cuenta de que había
dos patrones claros una era el de las
cosas que no nos gustaban y básicamente
centraba a aquellas personas que
debatían por debatir los profesionales
del debate gente que estaba acostumbrada
a conocer las normas y que iba allí pues
directamente a ganar y la segunda
aquello que nosotros hicimos un montón
de cosas absurdas sin sentido que no
servían para nada para ganar pero que
nos encantaban quiero utilizar el debate
como una herramienta no como un fin en
sí mismo sino como algo para conseguir
otros factores otros para otra
información otras habilidades que no de
por si el propio debate la verdad es que
hoy estoy más convencido que nunca
incluso de aquel día que el debate como
herramienta supera con infinitas creces
al debate como finalidad pero entonces
por qué todo el mundo debatida de esta
forma y porque en aquel torneo nosotros
éramos los raros pues poner sencilla
razón porque llegar a un torneo de
debate era imposible si no tenías
escuela lo nuestro fue un milagro que
llegasen cuatro perfectos desconocidos a
un torneo sin conocer ni siquiera a
reglas jamás pasaba porque se invitaba a
capitanes se invitaba a mentores e
invitaba escuelas de debate gente que
profesionalmente se dedicaba a eso como
un profesional iba a dejar que alguien
llegase para ver fuera de la caja que es
precisamente lo que nos pasó a nosotros
éramos tan malos que veíamos el debate
de otra forma y eso jamás había pasado
además que incidía que por aquel
entonces todos los que participamos en
aquel torneo éramos representantes
universitarios año 2010 y nos habían
encargado transformar la universidad
hacia los nuevos planes de estudios
bolonia eurocrédito eran momentos de
cambios pero tremendamente frustrantes
porque intentamos cambiar tantas cosas y
nos dejaron cambiar tan pocas y los
cambios que hicimos funcionaron tan mal
fue tan desastre que lo vimos clarísimo
dijimos todo lo que hemos aprendido en
este torneo de debate no es más que lo
que queremos llevar a la educación pongo
un ejemplo no recuerdo ni un momento ni
un momento de mis intervenciones durante
el debate tan solo que perdí todas pero
sí que recuerdo y conservo la amistad de
una tutoría que tuve con un profesor de
física nuclear yo estudiante de derecho
y ciencias políticas y mis compañeros de
sociología ciencias políticas ade de
repente estábamos sentado con un físico
nuclear al que motivó tanto que
estudiantes de otras carreras le pides
en tutoría que cogió su instrumental nos
subió a la azotea del edificio espero
que sigas en las condiciones apropiadas
y nos demostró como con viento y con
lluvia había trazas de chernóbil
completamente inocuas pero para nosotros
aquello fue revelador igual que para que
el profesor al que nunca nadie le había
pedido tutoría para preguntarle algo
fuera de programa después de 30 años de
docencia estaba frustrado lo curioso es
que nosotros yo mismo la primera tutoría
que pedí en mi universidad no fue de
derecho romano fue de física nuclear
algo que no tenía nada que ver con lo
que me iba a examinar cuatro meses
después o un año después esto era lo que
queríamos implantar estas ganas de
aprender por sí mismo aplicando un
pensamiento crítico brutal saliéndose de
cualquier paradigma de cualquier esquema
fomentando la inquietud y adquiriendo
contenidos y habilidades era perfecto y
cuando preguntamos a los profesores para
ver oye este problema que conservamos
nuestro existe de verdad nos lo
reconocían estos son datos de hace muy
poquito 2017 donde seguimos con esta
lacra 3 con 92 el pensamiento crítico
nuestro sistema educativo sobre 10 4,25
habilidades comunicativas 4 25
investigación o capacidad de trabajar de
forma autónoma imaginaos con
rápido que va el mundo con la fake news
con toda la información que circula que
suspendamos en enseñar a la gente a
buscar por sí mismo información da mucho
que pensar pero lo peor de todo es si de
verdad creemos que el sistema educativo
sirve para fomentar líderes y suspende
con un 3 quién narices estamos haciendo
y esto era lo que nos preguntamos
formamos un caballo de troya que
llamamos torneo de debate pero que no se
parece en nada a un torneo de debate
porque en realidad lo adornamos tanto le
pusimos tantos extras que en realidad
desvirtuamos el debate la hoja de ruta
fue aquello expósito que he enseñado en
la pared y lo que hicimos fue
básicamente poner estandarizar hacer que
el profesor y se guiase por un camino
que le llevase a utilizar el debate como
herramienta básicamente allá donde había
algo que no nos gustaba nos inventábamos
algo para neutralizarlo por ejemplo no
nos gustaba nada que los que debatiesen
fuesen élite si queríamos cambiar el
sistema educativo
teníamos que cambiarlo para todos los
alumnos no para los cuatro mejores a los
cuatro mejores de una clase los sueltas
en el desierto de tabernas con un euro y
esa gente aprende latín da igual
lo puedes poner boca abajo que van a
aprenderse la lección ponle más tarea la
van a sacar adelante los que nos
interesaban eran el resto de alumnos
aquellos que no tenían tantas
facilidades para estudiar entonces
empezamos a mandarles trabajo previo a
los docentes
en nuestro torneo si tú hacías cosas con
la clase antes te poníamos puntos con lo
cual es más fácil ganar
y fue relativamente satisfactorio porque
en vez de participar los cuatro mejores
participaron los ocho mejores
los docentes eran como reaccionó a que
alguien que sacaba malas notas de
repente pues representarse a su centro
en cualquier otro sitio hasta que dimos
con la clave y puntuamos muy bien
dábamos el doble de puntuación a
aquellos docentes que tres en un equipo
que habían elegido haciendo un torneo
previo en su aula no te decíamos que el
que gana se tiene que venir ni que el
que perdía se tenga que venir eso lo
decidían ellos pero nuestra sorpresa fue
que cuando el docente empezó a ver a
todos los alumnos debatir empezaron a
confeccionar sus equipos con alumnos que
tenían resultados mediocres o
directamente malos y esto tiene una
razón de ser súper sencilla la van a
entender el alumno malo es un alumno
tremendamente competitivo casi siempre
en la mayoría de los casos lo que pasa
que la competición no está alineada con
lo que el docente quiere me explico para
un alumno competitivo ganarle al
profesor es sacar un cero en su
asignatura porque le está retando y le
está ganando
para un alumno competitivo malo retar a
sus padres ganarle a sus padres sacar un
cero a la asignatura y llega un momento
que es cuando más disfrutan que es
cuando ya no te quedan herramientas como
educador o como padres para corregir el
rumbo ahí han conseguido el triunfo
máximo porque te me vas a matar
me vas a quitar la play ya me la ha
quitado me va a quitar el móvil me da
igual y eso nos pasaban las clases pero
cuando un alumno competitivo se enfrenta
a otro compañero no quiere perder por
nada del mundo y se da cuenta de que
para ganar tiene que aplicar toda la
disciplina que aprendió en el futbito
toda la creatividad que aprende jugando
a las cartas y todas las habilidades que
tiene de jugar al forn y está en
investigar trabajar los contenidos y
aprender lo mejor que el compañero y se
vuelven alumnos brillantes porque
descubren que pueden ganar por el lado
bueno y cuando pasa eso el alumno malo
deja de ser malo y se convierte en un
buen alumno lo segundo que no nos
gustaba era la competitividad pero
sabíamos que tiene un factor muy
positivo la competitividad une y desune
une a los equipos a una de las personas
de un mismo centro frente a otro centro
separa las personas de diferentes
centros lo primero que hicimos fue
mezclarlos en las habitaciones donde
dormía nosotros nos dimos cuenta que el
torneo en el que fuimos en el que los
equipos preparaban por la noche las
posturas nosotros queríamos tomar
cervezas con gente de otras
y no podíamos porque todo el mundo decía
no no no quita no vayas a ver me lo que
tengo preparado para mañana pero es que
hemos venido aquí sino a compartir
conocimientos no no no esto no puede ser
entonces mezclamos a la gente y
conseguimos un clima bueno la revolución
fue cuando nos dio por mezclar equipos
que perdían cuando un equipo empezaba a
perder lo sacamos del campeonato lo
mezclamos y lo volvíamos a introducir la
primera vez que hicimos esto se nos coló
en cuartos de final un equipo de 4
alumnos de centros diferentes y le ganó
al aspirante por una sencilla razón
porque mezclaron sus argumentos porque
los combinaron y porque al final
enfocaron el problema desde cuatro
puntos de vista diferentes conversaron
entre ellos la tercera cosa que no nos
gusta nada es cuando se frivolizaba y se
llevaban posturas opuestas al extremo y
esto pasaba mucho en el debate
lamentablemente a nosotros nos encantaba
construir desde puntos de vista común
establecíamos puntos en consenso con el
rival y a partir de ahí discutíamos es
decir en la energía nuclear estoy de
acuerdo en que los combustibles fósiles
hay que eliminarlos y que la energía
renovable es mejor que la energía
nuclear que me toca defenderla a favor
pero si queremos llegar a esta energía
renovable vamos a utilizar por el camino
me explico estoy aceptando puntos del
rival sin embargo lo normal de no no no
la energía renovable no sirve para nada
no va a llegar a nada no va a conseguir
nada lo mejor es la nuclear esto es lo
que pasaba siempre hasta que empezamos a
puntuar doble aquellos argumentos en los
que te vas abbas en comentarios o en
consenso con puntos del rival y pasó una
cosa curiosa se nos ocurrió un invento
dibujo completamente lo que entendemos
por el debate que era unirles las mesas
empezó a pasar que equipos compartían
documentos jugando al rival y decía
déjame estudio porfa utilizaban el mismo
estudio equipos contrarios lo último que
no nos gustaba nada por ejemplo que voy
a contarles hoy es
al final el relativismo que sucede
muchas veces en el debate de quedarse
ahí cuando tú tocas los dos puntos de
una misma postura puede pasar que al
final no defiendan ninguna de las dos
cosas porque bueno conoces todo dice
depende no nos volvemos como gallegos
ahora bien cuando te enfrentas a alguien
contra la vida para dar una respuesta al
debate que has preguntado esa persona
tiene que decidir y cuando decide
incorpora los elementos que ha aprendido
los elementos que ha vivido para dar una
respuesta y así hemos hecho un montón de
acciones que luego voy a contar
donde los estudiantes salían a la calle
y se convertían en agentes de cambio no
sé voy a contar luego porque antes le
voy a contar porque hacíamos todo esto
yo suelo preguntarle a mis alumnos lo
decirle a mis alumnos que la
inteligencia se mide en las veces que
uno se pregunta por qué esto para mí es
clave la razón de por qué hacemos esto
era por dos cosas la primera porque
descubrimos que el debate era una
herramienta potentísima para cambiar la
educación una herramienta potente para
instalar un cambio sistémico en el aula
que fuese capaz de voltear la educación
completamente basarla en el pensamiento
crítico basada en la iniciativa de los
estudiantes pasarlas en la inquietud de
los mismos
así nos dimos cuenta de que por ejemplo
los temas que tratábamos antes de
tratarlos los docentes decían que los
estudiantes no sabían tanto como para
aprobar sin embargo cuando terminaban
los docentes decían que sacaban un
sobresaliente lo curioso es que los
alumnos decían lo mismo por el pilares
alumnos y docentes coinciden en
evaluarse a sí mismos la mayoría de
ellos además el cien por cien decía que
los temas que planteamos retos globales
de futuro no se trabajaban en el sistema
educativo en retos globales como la
inteligencia artificial la desigualdad
el hambre las guerras en retos que
cambio climático que nos van a afectar
en poco tiempo las segundas que
queríamos un impacto directo de la
educación sabemos que la educación tiene
un impacto indirecto clave al final
todos los que estamos aquí hacemos lo
que hacemos por la educación que hemos
recibido y si hubiésemos recibe una
educación diferente actuaremos de forma
diferente pero si la educación
pudiésemos impactar de forma real y
directa en el día a día esas son 217
acciones en 2017 de 376 en 2018 como
debatir en un bar para contarle a la
gente lo que han investigado o como por
ejemplo irse a un supermercado
a ponerle un etiquetado de la huella
ecológica que tiene cada producto para
que el consumidor entienda lo que está
contaminando al medio ambiente cuando
compra un brick o una botella de cristal
o por ejemplo irse a una cadena de
restaurantes de comida rápida para
explicar cuánta agua es necesaria para
producir una hamburguesa y cómo
curiosamente es mucho mejor que dejes de
comer una hamburguesa a que dejes de
ducharte durante un mes o irse a los
taxistas para convertirlos en
influencers del cambio hacia el vehículo
eléctrico si ellos eran los que más
disfrutaban de los del patrimonio de la
ciudad tenían que utilizar su capacidad
decir oye qué coche me compro el que se
compre un taxista pues vamos a convencer
a los taxistas de que se pasen al al
vehículo eléctrico esto fueron un poco
las acciones que tuvimos hoy en día
participan con nosotros unos 130 centros
en españa y méjico antes de que acabe el
curso abriremos 5 países y esperamos
llegar a los 200 centros jóvenes
promesas una organización que hace de
ella o que por lo menos consigamos algo
más de 100 personas
es completamente gratuita para todos sus
participantes pero porque funciona
funciona en base a nuestra experiencia
por tres cosas la primera porque es una
metodología educativa anti frágil está
pensada para el docente para que la
curva precisa que sea muy corta para que
se pueda implantar rápidamente para que
ningún docente que no quiere aplicarla
estropee y para que sea un docente en un
aula con una unidad didáctica el que
empiece el cambio si la metodología
empiezan de arriba abajo nuestra
experiencia nos dice que no funcionan si
las empieza quien está realmente con el
estudiante y ve cambios entonces
funciona la mayoría bueno no el 100% de
nuestros centros viene porque docentes
han querido aplicar el programa en su
centro
después se contagia en otros docentes la
dirección los apoya pero el motor el
origen el impulsor siempre un docente
los segundos porque la necesidad
imperiosa tenemos que poner sobre la
mesa retos que nos afectan que nos
enfrentan como sociedad global y que no
estamos tocando en la educación y que
sean nuestros jóvenes que tengan que
responder y tenemos que entrenarnos en
pensamiento crítico y en liderazgo y no
hacemos nada de esto además los
contenidos se quedan obsoletos el joven
tiene cada vez más inquietud y necesita
aplicar las cosas rápido en el día a día
y la tercera cosa es que hablar en clase
es bueno si hablamos en clase
al final empieza un aprendizaje de pares
se revierte la vertical del profesor y
pasa una cosa preciosa que es parecida a
lo que aquí tenemos como cantes de ida y
vuelta del flamenco que al final un
canto y de vuelta es un cante que se
cantaba en cádiz un tanguillo un señor
de cádiz se va hasta colombia lo canta
allí recibe el son colombiano de la
guajira y se vuelve y dice oye voy a
cantar un tanguillo y el gaditano le
dice eso en algún tanguillo eso es otra
cosa es otra cosa preciosa que se llama
colombiana pues lo mismo pasa con las
ideas y con los conocimientos cuando los
estudiantes son los que se lo explican a
propios estudiantes y esto es
maravilloso clases que participan son
clases que funcionan así que por favor
de este remos el no hables en clase que
estamos acostumbrados decir quiero
terminar muy grave con dos reflexiones
la primera es
somos nosotros los que ponemos límites a
la educación de nuestros hijos
si os dais cuenta los libros están para
conseguir alcanzar eso que dice el libro
los estándares están para conseguir
tenerlos cuando algún alumno pregunta en
un examen que entra entra esto y si se
pregunta si entra algo más y si no eso
no entra de hecho se dice no eso no te
lo he preguntado cuando un alumno
responde a algo más imaginaos que en
lugar de plantearnos un estándar
educativo
por ejemplo los señores los curas que
defendieron a los indígenas padres
mariana con la conquista de américa en
el descubrimiento de américa es un
estándar nuevo en la educación española
imaginaos que en lugar de adquirir ese
estándar y estudiarlo fuese el punto de
partida para empezar a investigar otras
cosas como por ejemplo si sería bueno
lanzarnos a la búsqueda de vida
extraterrestre
y el joven empieza a entender todo lo
que ha estudiado para aplicarlo a un
problema que es real qué pasará si bien
una raza desconocida qué pasará si viene
alguien de fuera habrá alguien que nos
defienda habrá un padre mariana nos hará
falta
lo segundo es
somos nosotros los que ponemos límites a
la capacidad de nuestros hijos y esto es
muy triste pero eso nos llena la boca de
decir que son los jóvenes los que
cambiarán el mundo que son los jóvenes
los que traerán ideas frescas en
realidad a la hora de la verdad ni los
entrenamos ni los escuchamos ni
confiamos en ellos somos despóticos
ilustrados con nuestros hijos todo para
nuestros hijos pero si nuestros hijos
les pido que hagan un ejercicio cuando
lleguen a casa vayan a su hijo a su
nieto a su hermano menor al colega de su
hermano a quien sea y pregúntenle por
ejemplo
qué harían ellos mañana para reducir la
desigualdad o pregúntenle si quieren
sacar los coches de las ciudades
o qué piensan de que una máquina llega a
ser más inteligente que un humano lo van
a pasar genial van a descubrir que sus
hijos tienen un potencial enorme y les
van a ayudar porque les van a ser
preguntas que en dos tres cuatro o cinco
años van a tener que responder y cuanto
antes empiecen a responderlas mejor lo
harán en un futuro
termino
si creemos que la educación es la
herramienta más poderosa para conseguir
que nuestros hijos líderes en el cambio
de los problemas que les hemos dejado
vamos a dejar de limitar la educación y
vamos a dejar de limitar a nuestros
hijos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]